If it's okay,
we wanna talk real estate, with you, in the news.
Oh my god, nothing else we like to do more.
(audience laughs)
Perfect.
Well, our recent survey actually said,
that many people would happily skip sex to surf Zillow.
(audience laughs)
I mean, I don't think of online as a porn opportunity,
I think of it as a real estate opportunity.
Yeah, people are into some freaky stuff,
and my fetish is a sunken living room
and an open concept kitchen.
(laughing)
That's what I'm into and no shame.
Yep, exactly.
Don't even get me started on a good school district.
Oh my God.
I could lose it!
All right.
Well, we got us some properties, we want to get
your opinion on, here's a hot one in Lake Tahoe.
It's a duplex.
It offers 2,000 square feet
for the small price tag of $650,000.
Oo, that's steep.
And the Daily Mail reports, "It comes complete
with rooms, and rooms, of dressy mannequins.
Mannequins glamorously lounging about the living space
dressed to the nines,
near the kitchen.
You know, this place will cost an arm and a leg.
(audience laughing)
So stupid.
Okay, Natasha, Dan, it's $650,000
and you get the mannequins.
Is that a steal?
Okay, here's the problem.
There is no good way to get rid of that many mannequins
without seeming like a serial killer.
Absolutely.
Most upsetting thing for me is that all these mannequins
are wearing outfits that Natasha owns,
and that's what really freaks me out.
Oh my God.
I wish it was like that Kim Cattrall movie,
remember Mannequin?
Oh, and then there was Mannequin 2,
like 'On The Move' or something.
Yeah, I kind of fast-forward through that one.
(laughing)
Okay, our next listing went viral, because it's just
oozing with 1970's charm.
The New Haven Register reports
that this four bedroom, in Fort Wayne, Indiana,
is covered in wall to wall shag carpet.
All 2,476 square feet designed in 1975 by architect
James Sherbondy.
The carpets and stains are all original.
The stains are original, Drew's in!
I know. By the way, I'm like, let me at this house
with a bottle of Draft.
A family from Orlando put in an offer,
before stepping foot into the place.
Dan, Natasha, thoughts?
I mean, this house is kind of looking to me like
Ross Matthew's house, if he never left his hometown.
(audience laughing)
You don't even know how dead on that is.
(laughing)
Right? I actually was looking at those pictures
of me, thinking to myself, like, it's not bad.
I'm kinda into it.
I mean, look that house for starters, those lines
they're just beautiful.
The carpet is literally hot watermelon color.
(laughing)
I mean, the shag goes up to the edge of the tub.
Can you imagine that, that carpet has never been changed?
No.
Can you even imagine what is inside that carpet?
I don't want to.
No, it's not a house where you have to take off your shoes
and put on platform shoes to not step on the crunchy spots.
(laughing)
Oh my god, I kind of love it.
All right.
Next up, the site House Beautiful posted about a two bed,
two bath house in Zephyr Hills, Florida.
It's described as quote,
"Literally the worst house on the street."
Okay, listen to this.
The roof leaks, the floor creaks,
and there's quote, "A terrible draft throughout the house."
Which means it's very open concept,
and that also several of the windows are broken.
And despite all of that, it sold for $51,000.
So, what do you think the new owners are planning to do?
Good investment?
Well, all I know is that in LA,
this house is 1.7 million dollars.
(laughing)
This is the kind of house you had to wear a mask,
you know, during the open house, but it was before COVID.
It was that, that bad.
Oh, but I kind of love the optimism in that.
Somebody looked at that house and thought,
"There's something beautiful here."
I loved that the realtor was just straight up honest,
and was like, "Yes, this is a piece of, you know what.
It's got no walls.
It's a dump,
it's a disaster.
And it's 51,000."
That honesty I found very refreshing.
Okay. And finally, we've got an adorable story
about some mini real estate in Calabasas.
Buzzfeed reports that Kim Kardashian has built
an adorable tiny town in her backyard for her kids.
Just take a look at these pics.
Oh my gosh.
I know. There's a diner,
an ice cream shop, and even a mini KKW beauty store.
Don't you want it?
Like the little Ross wants a little town like that.
I wish I could go on my childhood
and there'd be like, you know, a drag, brunch, place there,
a little cabaret theater for me-
Like the French Market Quarter in West Hollywood?
Yes!
Natasha, Dan, what would you want?
I would want, like, a teeny little day spa
where I could get my nose done-
(laughing muffles voice)
I want to get rid of these wrinkles, right here, you know?
Like whatever that is, like, puff them up a little bit.
Yeah, get some Lego injections.
Whatever you need.
You guys, can we please do this again?
A hundred percent, our schedules are wide open.
And we're down.
Dan Levy and Natasha Leggero, we love you.
Please, let this be the first of so many,
and you can catch these very funny humans to do a set
at none other than Bananamore's Virtual Comedy Club.
Yeah, we crushed it.
I will tell you right now, we were the funniest people on.
(laughing)
I am so excited about Bananamore's, because it
launches this Saturday on our YouTube channel.
And I just thought, you know, comedy clubs are
closed right now,
and I know they're trying to figure out their way back,
but we all need to laugh.
So, thank you so much, Natasha and Dan, and of course,
obviously, you can catch them on House Hunters,
Comedians On Couches, Unfiltered on Discovery Plus.
Right now it is the most delicious way to spend your time.
I love it.
And I love you guys, I'm so happy for you.
Well done, you guys.
Thank you!
See you soon.
(upbeat music)